quand c'est positif ya deux traits qui
apparaissent s'il n'y a qu'un trait au
bout d'un quart d'heure ça veut dire que
le test est négatif
isolé au plus vite les cas positifs
identifier les asymptomatiques à la
verrière on a fait le choix du test
antigénique pratiqué par les infirmières
installé sur la commune
les municipalités ont un rôle à jouer
pour freiner l'épidémie et grâce aux
infirmières libérales du bois de l'étang
on a organisé en un temps record cette
séance de testing avec des tests
antigénique qui permettent d'avoir des
résultats entre 15 et 30 minutes donc
des résultats quasiment immédiatement
pour être assuré pour s'isoler le plus
rapidement possible au cas échéant ou
pour reprendre le travail
venus pour beaucoup se rassurer les
premiers patients bénéficier des
dépistages gratuits proposés depuis
samedi 14 novembre
je voulais savoir si j'étais positives
et négatives finalement je suis négative
a lancé bon la période qu'on a
actuellement bon on sait pas si on est
porteur si on ne l'est pas et petit bois
au moins comme ça c'est fait qu'on ait
une information même si on peut être
après qu'un contact ou pas con je suis
chauffeur de car de tourisme et on ne
sait pas qui monte dans dans le car
quand on fait les lignes et tout ça donc
j'en ai profité pour pouvoir faire mon
test est la commune met à disposition
une salle au sein du scarabée
l'opération sera répétée chaque samedi
de 9 heures à 13 heures une soixantaine
de tests ont été réalisés pour ce
premier rendez vous